[Musique]
ne tombez pas dans les pièges du
marketing
pour vous aider l'épicerie lève le voile
sur certaines techniques utilisées par
l'industrie pour vous vendre ses
produits aujourd'hui
le marketing en épicerie
contournez les étalages éphémères vous
avez des étalages éphémères toutes
sortes de prêts sur votre parcours de
l'entrée jusqu'au 15 là où ça devient un
piège c'est que ces produits là sur les
étalages éphémères ça nous donne souvent
l'impression qu'ils sont en promotion
puisqu'on les mettant de l'avant mais ce
n'est pas toujours le cas c'est pas mal
tous déjà fait prendre je pense à mettre
un produit de nettoyage éphémère dans
notre panier pour se rendre compte à la
caisse que non il n'était pas en solde
ces étalages là aussi ont comme effet
direct de ralentir notre parcours et en
prenant plus de temps ça nous incite à
mettre les yeux et les pieds dans des
directions qu'on aurait peut-être
reprises si l'étalage en question
n'avait pas été là
méfiez-vous des promotions parfois il y
a des rabais qui peuvent être alléchant
et pas toujours les promotions sont
probablement la stratégie la plus
efficace à utiliser dans une épicerie
pour nous inciter à dépenser davantage
il y a plusieurs approches
promotionnelles les classiques qu'on
connaît donc une réduction de prix
temporaire soit sur des
items un nombre d'items ou au poids des
promotions avec achats multiples dont on
sera un peu moins compte qui est aussi
très efficace c'est ce qu'on appelle les
promotions croisées donc entendre entre
deux entreprises qui font des produits
complètement différents mais qui peuvent
être complémentaires pour nous inciter
en fait à considérer les deux donc par
exemple à l'achat d'un pain x obtenez le
rabais y sur telle confiture
ou à l'achat d'une caisse de bière
obtenez un sac de croustique gratuit là
où ça devient véritablement un piège
c'est toujours lorsque ça nous fait
dépenser pour quelque chose dont on n'a
pas véritablement besoin pour moi
l'enjeu est particulièrement ce qui
concerne le gaspillage parce qu'on sait
que c'est un enjeu majeur c'est presque
10% des gaz à effet de la planète qui
proviennent que des déchets alimentaires
donc faut vraiment qu'on fasse attention
à ça autre tactique utilisée les
promotions sur une seule partie d'une
gamme de produits qu'est-ce que c'est je
me suis fait prendre encore récemment
disons une gamme de 5 sauces à spaghetti
avec des variétés différentes et
l'entreprise décéderait d'en mettre deux
sur cinq en promotion donc les
étiquettes sont claires sur la tablette
mais si on ne fait pas attention on peut
facilement avoir l'impression que
l'ensemble de la gamme est en promo on
prend celui qu'on préfère qui est pas
nécessairement celui qui est en promo et
on a la surprise à la caisse de
finalement avoir payé plus cher
en épicerie on ne s'en rend pas tout le
temps compte mais nous sans sont souvent
sollicités on commence par l'odorat la
position dans l'épicerie de la
boulangerie et très stratégique il y a
pas tellement d'odeurs plus agréables
que celle d'un peintre fraîchement sorti
du four le fait d'avoir cette odeur là
et vous remarquerez systématiquement aux
grandes heures d'affluence l'heure des
fournis et
jumeler avec les heures d'achalandage de
la clientèle bien sûr parce que tant
qu'à faire le pain frais je veux dire
même pour la clientèle c'est un avantage
de pouvoir partir avec un pain qui est
en quartier c'est toujours agréable mais
oui c'est des petits incitatifs subtils
du mercredi soir autre sens sollicité
Louis jusqu'à épuisement la radio en
magasin c'est pas les grandes stations
commerciales qui jouent les messages
sont complètement contrôlés par le
détaillant c'est très subtil c'est pas
fort mais c'est là on l'entend et
évidemment l'objectif de cette radio là
et de nous informer notamment de
promotions qui sont en cours ou de
découverte de nouveaux produits
finalement on joue aussi avec votre vue
le fameux panier de métal je sais pas
pour toi mais moi je me souviens très
bien des paniers quand j'étais petit ils
étaient pas mal plus petits
qu'aujourd'hui et ça a été très bien
documenté par plusieurs études comme
quoi la taille du panier avec laquelle
on fait nos achats à une influence
directe sur la quantité d'aliments qu'on
va se trouver à acheter et lorsque le
panier est plus grand et qu'on a
l'impression qu'il n'est pas aussi
rempli que d'habitude ça nous donne
l'impression qu'il nous manque quelque
chose alors on se met à chercher et on
le remplit davantage plus gros le panier
plus grosse la facture
absolument
les programmes de fidélité peuvent
devenir un piège si vous voulez si
séduire par tout ce qu'il vous propose
notre carte de points est-ce que ça vaut
vraiment la peine de l'utiliser chaque
achat ça peut valoir la peine et ce qui
rend certains programmes
particulièrement performants c'est ceux
qui arrivent à nous proposer des offres
vraiment personnalisées c'était très
difficile à venir jusqu'à tout récemment
mais depuis quelques années avec le
développement accéléré des nouvelles
technologies et de l'intelligence
artificielle les détaillants ont
maintenant accès à de l'information en
or sur nous sur tous nos comportements
toutes nos habitudes toutes nos
préférences
et d'une certaine façon oui il n'avait
pas la capacité à vendre de d'analyser
et de gérer toutes ces informations là
mais maintenant ils l'ont en fait la
critique ou l'évaluation numéro 1 vous
devriez faire par rapport à un programme
de fidélité en épicerie ou même ailleurs
est-ce que ce qu'on vous propose en
remise ou en retour de votre fidélité
vous apporte des avantages qui comptent
pour vous c'est la réponse c'est oui
allez-y c'est la réponse et non pas
c'est tout droit merci plaisir
[Musique]